ich dachte noch nie dass die beste
personen aller mitspieler in dieser
runde bin herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen videospiel wieder wm titel schon
gesehen habt ich hab noch nie wir sind
in diesem fall meine wenigkeit und
andrea durch den zweck haben wir die
alten viele leute und eine app die und
ich hab noch nie vorschläge für
szenarien geben wird wir wollen die
ganze geschichte der jungen frau an bord
des fsk 0 hinten rauskommen wieder ein
bisschen bei dieser frage das heißt fsk
sekten oder etwas weitergehen werden am
ende sehen viel spaß
ich habe noch nie weil man alter gelogen
doch wer noch nie über sein alter
gelogen vor allem jever somit die
jüngsten deutschen und freundeskreisen
und sogar gerne dafür nirgendwo hingehen
wollte muss man immer wird ein alter
ich hatte keinen freund also ich habe
einfach unterwegs unter medizin gelernt
hat da war schon mal so zwei drei jahre
aufgeschoben
ich bin noch nie ohne führerschein auto
getan würde ja auch nie machen leute ich
habe viel zu viel gebe schon richtig
schlecht wenn ich besoffen auch schon
freut sich schon mit 14 auto gefahren er
verlangte von seinem vater bekommen
und welcher vater gibt ist diese frage
ich habe noch nie machen gesagt dass
jemand anderes diese these unterricht
ist also ein dutzend mädchen hingeht und
sagt mein freund ist nicht verliebt doch
habe ich glaube ich bin mir nicht sicher
wir bringen jetzt mal eine echte frage
ich habe mir noch mir jemanden schön
betrunken dh du kannst irgendjemanden
mit dem du was haben wolltest aber war
zu hässlich und hast du gesagt ich
brauche es damit ich dich aus
niemand der durst locker gemacht du hast
ihn überhaupt geringer wenn ich dann
zutrauen würden die leute mir die welt
keine namen von unschuld videopodcast
der nichte sich schwer tun
wo bin ich gerade ist werden ihnen doch
klar ich hab nur chance sondern
rausgefischt so aber in der tonne mit
dem container wirkt die gesamte kinder
etwas zu gewohnt im schrank wasser
[Musik]
ich habe noch nie mit ihm schluss
gemacht während ich verärgert war und
danach bereut ich meine aber dass noch
ganz vage man sich trennt dass man im
ersten moment denkst du bist bin ich nie
los und eine woche später denkt man sich
so auch weil es wegen kinderschändung
dann nimmt man sich verliert man schon
mal bereut pflanzt sich immer durch die
entscheidung gewesen aber nie papier
gegessen
die hostessen hier drauf gekommen
ich hab noch nie per sms schluss gemacht
heute ich hab ja nicht per sms schluss
gemacht aber ich habe noch nie
fahrerflucht begangen eine schwere liga
ist eine video sagen würde also fahrer
flog heißt leute wenn ihr mit eurem auto
oder irgendwie ähnlichen verkehrsmittel
eine person zum beispiel raum termin
schaden anrichten strafe und dann weg
war völlig richtig kraftwerk an ihr der
führerschein abgenommen werden
glück richtige ich hab noch nie gemacht
natürlich aber selbstverständlich auch
wenn ich gemacht hätte billig sondern
bionik zu geben also die polizei ist
teilweise schon auch mal videos
polizeipräsenz die letzte strafe der
hessischen polizei wagenfeld aber und da
ich hab noch nie mit einer berühmten
person gesprochen
ich habe schon mal luca deswegen also
die klimaeffekte witzige kommentare zu
einem kleinen die angst der präsentation
zu halten
als ob du hattest bestimmt schon
irgendwann für eine freudvolle
präsentation nicht auch mir wirklich
nicht ich war schon sehr gut vielleicht
richtig geil was bei der präsentation
deine eltern als die griechen
präsentiert ich hab noch nie eine
peinliche sms aus versehen an die
falsche person geschickt ja locker warum
immer sms mms
er hat doch alle ich mehr hinzurichten
weil ich einfach die namen eingegeben
habe und natürlich ein bild dabei in den
fällen die falsche person ausgelegt die
einfach in dem geschäftspartner ist auch
ein trockener kaufen sondern würde den
neuen trockner kaufen wollten ich dachte
noch nie dass die beste person aller
mitspieler runde bin ehrlich gesagt
nicht nur ein bisschen fett gerade okay
leute zum abschluss setzt die
versprochenen fsk fragen würde sagen wir
hatten zeit auch mal etwas charakter hat
im letzten jahr nicht was im liedtext
mehr im meer im meer
wie hieß es wasser rein die hose runter
und was wenn du kleines baby wird
ich hab noch nie professionell
nacktfotos von ihr machen lassen ich
wohl tatsächlich mal gefragt ohne
stichwahl im berliner kaufhaus werden
kann die wir oder so und dann kam sie zu
mir mein leben nicht immer lustig wenn
seine visitenkarte ist es ab und ist
dann einfach so größtenteils sehr
endhöhe fotos irgendwie an alles gedacht
haben
beschreibung bis zum nächsten mal darum
und